Everyone says it's fine, but
I'm fine, so if it's going to be
easy, I'm a third grader in the fighting game world.
But on the day of the performance
, despite being vaccinated, I caught mumps and missed the
school arts festival.  I
practiced until late at night every day and was able to set the top time in my grade,
but on the day of the performance, I
was attacked by a sudden muscle strain during the entrance and declined to participate.
I became a relay player
Each time I was attacked by moving into the entrance area It's a
bad memory
In the summer of my first year in junior high school
I was aiming for a prestigious school,
until then I loved music program dramas
Time with friends To that first year old
I spent my entire junior high school life studying
[music]
Music] On the
day of the
entrance exam, I stayed at a hotel near the venue from the day before,
just in case.  It's a memory like I
couldn't go to manual school